artur artesi babayev was born on july 1
1996 in tashkent uzbekistan but he grew
up in vancouver canada
now a successful pro and a controversial
community personality
artesi is making his mark as one of the
most influential dota players in the pro
scene today
make it an ultra our tour unstoppable
despite being only 21 years old and
starting his pro career at 16
artesi has already amassed quite the
career for himself
this is his story
[Music]
when he was growing up artesi honed his
skill and love of competition playing
the original dota and starcraft 2.
hello it's about time
but it was in dota 2 where he would gain
notoriety in late 2012 and early 2013
artesi was often cited as one of the
best and non-pro
pub stars in north america it's a double
kill for rtz 16-3
and i'm even wondering right now if gg
is on the mind of nafi
dazzling with his individual skills and
game sense on heroes such as puck
he gained further attention as the
community learned he served as
training partner to pros such as bulba
and s4
who praised the young player for his
mid-lane play and obvious talents
with his tremendous mechanical skill
helping him climb the mmr leaderboard
and draw even more eyes to his potential
everyone expected artesi would quickly
find a home
in the professional scene artesi opted
to delay his full-time debut to focus on
his education
but during the school break in summer of
2013 artesi
did temporarily join kaipe the team
performed poorly overall
with their best showing being a second
place finish in the defense season
4. in november of 2013 artesi was asked
to stand in for bone 7 on speed gaming
international at mlg columbus
there he would not only help speed take
the title but would prove his medal
against some of the best teams and
players the world had to offer
including mushi s4 and dendy
and you know you're you're you're
standing in so is it just all gravy
for you is it just like whatever you
know yeah it's great because uh there's
no like stress on me if we lose really
i like let my team down let my fans down
that's it but
i'm like i don't know it's like just
like standing in for a team that's it
his deep champion pool and excellent
laning were on full display as he rocked
the competition on timbersaw
outworld devourer and marana his
performance was another clear indication
that artesi could cut it at the top tier
and he gained even more hype around his
competitive future
as if it were possible dude he [ __ ]
won though
then in early 2014 artesi joined up with
na veterans
fear and universe as well as the heroes
of newerth talent
of ppd and zai to form sad boys
the team instantly clicked taking first
at the electronic sports
prime shock therapy cup over team empire
without dropping a single game
and there it is wow empire will tap out
we have a champion we have we have five
champions ld
before this final series sad boys are
12-1
on 6.8 and competitive matches are now
going to be 14-1 that's a
pretty solid record for a new team on
the block are they going to turn into
the happy boys
when sad boys were picked up by evil
geniuses a month later
the time had finally come artesi was
ready to commit to playing dota 2
full time eg made their highly
anticipated debut under the new sponsor
at the monster energy invitational
winning the event and wasting no time in
establishing themselves as an elite
force in the dota world
shortly after gg well played
a series that went the distance a run
back
of what we saw in our upper bracket
finals cloud9 and evil geniuses
took us five games but eg tallies that
third win
and walks away are winners during this
time artesi was already showing off his
flexibility
and the depth of his hero pool proving
his value to the team in nearly
any scenario he's definitely one of the
best solo mid players at the moment i
think he probably might have just fixed
yourself
yep he did you may have just done that
eg's performance earned them a direct
invite to ti4
artesi's first time playing for dota's
biggest prize
and the aegis of champions the group
stage went
very well for eg the team's flexibility
and ppd's clever drafting allowed them
to adapt quickly to their opponents and
the push-heavy meta of the events
artesia performed well on the likes of
dragon knight the flavor of the
tournament
razer and his pocket naga siren which
has gone on to be a stable of his play
they lost two tier fours for this eg
finished the group stage and second
with a record of 11 and four securing a
spot in the upper bracket
there they once again defeated team dk
before losing to newbie
2-0 in the upper bracket final enigma tp
it's over gg newbie have won
five best of threes in a row and are
going to the grand finals they are
guaranteed
a top two finish eg eventually finished
third
losing to vichy gaming two to one in the
lower bracket after a brutal 15-minute
smackdown
in game three eg bass and it's gg
they got too greedy and vichy punish it
again
what a way to go out after their
elimination many fans and analysts point
to the finger at artesi's questionable
hand of midas buy
during the crucial game three regardless
of his mistake
artesi's ti debut further hyped fans for
the future of his career
[Music]
artesi continued to increase his profile
outside of his pro performances
with a highly entertaining stream and
his eccentric if controversial
personality time for your boy dj rtc to
bust a [ __ ] rhyme let's go
to our [ __ ] cue where is my game
gaben i see you up there throwing shade
his love of hip-hop and cocky arrogant
attitude earned him a reputation as a
heel of the community
now basically now everyone knows about
my dota stuff everybody knows
all the girls and sometimes when i'm
like eating they call me a god it's
really weird
they call you a god but that didn't stop
fans from gathering around him following
ti4
eg continued to find the wins taking
first at the world esports championships
starladder star series season 10 and
dream league season 2.
congratulations let's give him another
hand
the success all was not perfect within
the team artesi
well known for his ego and tendency to
be vocal in his displeasure
often clashed with another ego equally
as stubborn as his
the captain of the team ppd i mean
there's definitely a lot of personal
beef i think
myself on our tour have always had some
clashing heads
just because we have two very strong
personalities our tour
believes you know in his way to play
dota and i believed in my way to play
dota while their conflict didn't
directly prevent the team from winning
it did create significant tension and so
on january 6th
2015 it was announced that artesi had
moved to team secret as their position 1
player
the move was met with a mountain of fan
expectation
with artesi on the roster secret could
prove to be one of the best teams in the
world
the new secrets debut was red hot and
they went undefeated in the group stage
at the dota 2 asia championships with a
15-0 record
unfortunately the team took a tumble in
the winner's semi-final to vici gaming
and would eventually be ousted from the
tournament in shocking fashion by
you guessed it evil geniuses this
disaster secret
looks to be out of dac 2015
eg will find their way in the grand
finals best of five tomorrow versus
vichy gaming artisi show that
he's great with some heroes but he
wasn't that great with some others we
saw the medusa experiment wasn't that
amazing in the lane the next few events
for secret were a mixed bag
but the team finally clicked in the lead
up to ti5
winning four straight tournaments with
significant wins over the likes of
invictus gaming
and e.g
[Music]
with secret looking so dominant in
artesi in peak form
many predicted the squad was a favorite
for the title at t.i
history however tells a different story
they're moving forward gg well-played
secret college vp of eliminated the fan
favorites of this tournament
and they will move on and face up
against lgd in the losers bracket
we absolutely do thank you very much the
light will go out on
team secret they have been eliminated
the loss was a devastating blow to
artesian secret
and easily the biggest setback in his
career at that point
with finger pointing and blame gaming
rampant in secret following the loss and
the team's ego becoming a clear problem
a shuffle was inevitable and and tried
to ignore my hate for kuro
i could have done more but i blew the
[ __ ] up
and i [ __ ] up and i may have
contributed to the loss of ti
i don't belong on a team like secret
anyways
too uh different i think kuroki is
yeah that's it on august 14th he would
return to evil geniuses as their one
position player
in order to make room for artezy evil
geniuses kicked support player aoi 2000
just days after they won ti5 many
question eg's morality in removing aoi
so soon after winning dota's biggest
prize while still
others questioned if the team would be
able to move past the clash of egos that
had fractured it during artesi's
first tenure with the squad i mean
obviously like beef between me and rtz
was like the reason why
he left um so i'm not gonna really talk
about it
i don't really care about like what
people
think i want to meet my expectations i
want to
win a ti that's all i'm thinking about
eg was upset
2-0 by vegas squadron at esl one new
york in early october and there it is gg
under 30 minutes 22 is the unlucky
number here for eg it was 22-0
over a year ago and now it's 22-8 vega
will eliminate eg
and for the first time they don't find
themselves in the esl one final
but eg like they they swap out a aui to
bring in our tour
and how was that all gonna function
currently
maybe a couple of bumps down the road
heading into the frankfurt major eg was
once again a
serious contender there they swept their
group and the first two rounds of the
upper bracket
it seemed only destiny that in the upper
bracket finals they would meet team
secret
a match they would lose two and one
after a dramatic game one slugfest
with gg eg will be knocked out
of the winners bracket final by team
secret
and team secret advanced themselves
forward into the grand
final of the of the frankfurt major
going forward if eg play like this
probably still a favorite to reach the
grand finals again which would then be a
full best of five
they now have a little bit more
experience but it's very typical eg
tournament performance
a little bit weekday one they get
knocked out winter bracket finals down a
lower bracket but no one's too worried
because they usually come back through
and
get back to the grand finals so i think
they have a very likely chance of
beating og i don't think it's going to
be completely one-sided i think they
could lose it
they've got to be on their best behavior
dropped into the lower bracket they met
up against og
who were on a tear but still only
narrowly edged past eg
two and one easy gets chopped up he's
down for the count
no buyback for a hundred universe could
be next gg
once again had come up short of a title
at a val event
undeterred by the result eg closed out
the year winning the summit four and
kicked off 2016 well
with back-to-back finals appearances at
star ladder i-league season 1 and the
mars tv dota 2 league
at the shanghai major however eg's run
was eerily similar to their run
at frankfurt a strong group stage
showing only to be run out of the
winner's bracket by team secret two and
one
and it's gg
secret take the series 2-1
pretty much what they were looking at
in the lower bracket eg was once again
eliminated in third
this time by team liquid burning it out
there it is
team liquid they will take it 2-0
against evil geniuses with two
disappointments at the majors made worse
by defeats at the hands of secret
plus only one title victory in half a
year frustration
was building in the eg camp artesi
shocked the dota world by deciding to
return
to team secret this time bringing
universe with him in a blockbuster move
unlike artesi's first move to secret the
move proved to be a complete disaster
right from the get-go the new secret
despite having one of the most skilled
rosters
ever assembled was even more ego-charged
than eg
and struggled with communicating
effectively in key moments
secret flopped at esl one manila
epicenter 2016
and bombed out of both the manila major
and ti6
in last place
it's all too much for them secret are
going hard
it was another crushing blow for artesi
made all the worse by the fact that many
of the losses were embarrassments at the
hands of lesser teams like alliance
empire or lgd gaming while artesi's
in-game performance suffered
right alongside secrets outside the game
he continued to be an incredible popular
personality
however his near-constant roster jumping
reputation as a heel and a rager
made him a target for means and baby
comments
while some were devoted in their support
others jumped on the artesi hate
bandwagon
during this time artesi was famously
involved for his mmr race with og's
miracle
a well-publicized competition between
two of the world's
elite players on june 28th artesi
reached
9k mmr becoming only the second player
to achieve the rank behind
miracle clearly while his performance
with secret had been lackluster
his individual skills were still as
sharp as ever
on september 16 2016 artesi
rejoined evil geniuses for the third
time
well it feels okay to be back in eg uh
actually this is hard to answer man
oh my god yeah i need to think about so
i'm trying to think of something to say
that i haven't said before about last
time i left and stuff
so it's actually quite hard i think
we're capable of winning for sure
i also think we're capable of losing so
it was clear that the terrible showing
at ti6 was the straw that broke the
camel's back
this time however the roster saw a
significant shake-up
ppd moved off the active roster and into
a management role
instead replaced by crit i think he's a
little more laid back than i was i think
i was very
like authoritative and like not like
dictator but like
pretty like i was pretty a strong
personality and i think he's more
kind of easy going but he also i've seen
him he's capable of like really
making taking things seriously and i
know that like artur and zai
and sumail and stuff they all really
really get along with him
so i think that's something that's
really important too and i don't think
they
they bash heads as much as i used to do
with like sumail for example
and our tour the universe was also
brought back in
adding some much needed stability into
the roster without the clashes between
himself and ppd
artesi returned to form in come sumail
looking for the punish he'll bring down
q zai stays alive the breathe fire will
finish him but arteezy collects the
quick
triple kill goes shroud cooling down
he's already at full health
he'll be just fine give him an ultra the
hood
pays off until today this has been one
of artesi's most successful periods
ever he has openly admitted that a
return to eg has helped him
shift from a more selfish carry focus
mindset
to become more of a team player and it's
paying off
eg took first at the mars dota 2 league
2016 autumn
china top 2016 dota pit season 5
the manila masters 2017 to add to top
fours at the boston major
the summit 6 the kiev major and
epicenter of 2017.
a valve title a ti title still eludes
the talented canadian
nearly four years into his competitive
career artesi has accomplished
so much he's made himself into one of
dota 2's premier personalities
an elite carry player and a decorated
competitor
it's hard to argue that artesi isn't
only one of north america's best
he's one of na's most influential
players as well love him
or hate him there are still many mounts
to climb for rtz but looking back it's
fair to say
it wouldn't be the first time he's
overcome an obstacle
you